a minor classic come over a decade ago
is finding new life on Netflix a
streamer has released its top 10 list
for the third week of March and the wall
that were a good number of holdovers
from the week prior there were also a
few surprises perhaps the biggest
shocker is the appearance of Public
Enemies the 2009 historical drama
centered on the final years of the
infamous bank robber John Dillinger all
the way up at number 3 go to Chicago
makes money it's been fascinating to
watch the comings and goings of all the
Netflix originals animated flicks and
half-remembered features of yesteryear
since the top 10 list was rolled out by
Netflix in February 2020 the streamer
famously doesn't release its viewership
numbers but with a new feature we at
least have some idea of what our friends
and neighbors are feverishly binging
bracing the top 10 this week of the
Netflix original flicks the wronged
Missy at number 1 and John Henry at
number 5 along with the family animated
features so Willoughby's at number 6
Madagascar escaped to Africa at number 7
and the Grinch at number 10 and yes it's
nowhere near Christmas so we're not sure
what to make of that last one either a
documentary have a good trip adventures
and psychedelics acids at number 9 and
then there are the surprises the
inherited 2012 French sci-fi action err
lockout at number 8 a 2011 sports drama
Soul Surfer at number 2 and Public
Enemies at number 3 well the latter was
a minor commercial success upon its
release it didn't exactly set the world
on fire which is honestly a bit puzzling
because its pedigree is nothing short of
sterling if you're not familiar with the
work of Michael Mann then you've got
some movies to watch and the Public
Enemies is as good a place as any to
start the film features a veteran
director working at the absolute top of
his game calling the shots for legendary
cinematographer Dante's pranati
who was shot several of man's films
including Manhunter heat's and The
Insider much has been made of the fact
that the flick is a period piece shot on
high def video which on its surface is
an odd choice but spinozzi is a fan of
the format and is also an absolute
master at saturating is framed with
vivid colors and inky dark spaces the
film looks fantastic and it also
benefits from man celebrity yet fleet
pacing
boy you are in a hurry you're looking
what I'm looking at you'd be in a hurry
too then there's a cast which is simply
jaw-dropping Depp crushes there in the
role of Dillinger he's joined by
Christian Bale as FBI agent Melvin
Purvis Marion Cotillard is Dillinger's
girlfriend believed Frechette
Billy Crudup as FBI director J Edgar
Hoover and Steven Langa's Charles
Winstead a Texas lawman who fatally shot
Dillinger even the minor roles are
filled with ringers Stephen Dorff
appears as Homer van Meter Jason Clark
pops up as red Hamilton Giovanni Ribisi
appears as Alvin Karpis and none other
than Channing Tatum portrays Pretty Boy
Floyd
Public Enemies received mixed reviews
during its theatrical run with some
reviewers noting that the flick liked
the tension and drama that they had
expected from man whose modern classic
heat it's among the more tense films
ever made those critics who recommended
the film however saw it for what it was
an exhaustively researched incredibly
detailed film sports and great
performances from top to bottom of
course it will step you a singled out
for the most praised in his review of
the film at the great Roger Ebert wrote
this Johnny Depp performance as
something else but once an actor playing
a gangster does not seem to face his
performance on movies he has seen he
starts cold
he plays Dillinger as a fact this is a
very good film with Depp and Bale
performances of brutal clarity in
marking the film's 10th anniversary last
year
some critics opined that it was time for
a serious free appraisal of Public
Enemies which seems to be a recurring
theme with man's filmography one such
piece in The Washington Post astutely
pointed out that very few of the
directors films have been instant
smashes upon release as their distinct
style of craftsmanship seems to take a
while to catch on as general audiences
perhaps this is why with so many of us
suck a home and on the prowl for
something really great to watch this
once neglected gangster flick is finally
getting us to check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you